infections in the united states have
surpassed 25 million
and at this point hopes are lying with
the new vaccine being rolled out
now the new white house of joe biden is
promising to increase
vaccination rates and correct trump's
mistakes but now
things are going anything but smoothly
at this point the federal government
is admitting it's in the dark about how
much vaccine supply is available
i would say one of the biggest problems
right now is i can't tell you how much
vaccine we have
and if i can't tell it to you then i
can't tell it to the governors and i
can't tell it to the state health
officials
across the country vaccination
appointments are being cancelled by the
thousands here in new york city
23 000 vaccination appointments have
been cancelled
hospitals are running out unable to give
new inoculations
this has americans wondering if the new
administration can deliver
at this point time is is is is lives
like the longer
the pandemic extends itself
the more people die from something which
at this point
is literally a preventable condition
they have the capacity to do 10
000 vaccinations a day but they're only
doing
1500 because they don't have the doses
they don't have the supply
it is playing out nationwide a hospital
in virginia cancelled 10
000 first dose appointments another in
south carolina
canceled 6 000 scheduled vaccinations
after it received only 450 of the doses
it expected to get
in hawaii another hospital was forced to
cancel
5 000 scheduled appointments and put
another 15 thousand
requests on hold state governors across
the country are appealing to the federal
government for help
as frustration among the public is
growing we have
so many distributors that we can't
supply them all
and you will see distributors who run
out of supply
joe biden set the goal of 100 million
vaccinations in his first 100 days
criticizing donald trump along the way
for failing to achieve
high vaccination rates this criticism
was leveled by biden
even though the numbers of 1 million
vaccinations per day had already been
achieved by the previous administration
reporters tried to pin the white house
down about this not adding up none of us
are mathematicians myself included so i
asked our
team to do a little math on this so the
trump administration
they administered a total of about 17
million shots that's about
less than 500 000 shots a day what we
are proposing
is to double that to about 1 million
shots per day at his inauguration joe
biden promised to turn things around
when it came to the pandemic
however since then it has been a short
supply of vaccines
chaos and government officials shrugging
when asked how much is in supply
the biden administration needs to pick
up the pace and fast
if not they could risk bringing an end
to what would turn out to be one of the
shortest honeymoon periods
in u.s presidential history caleb maupin
rt new york
you